okay it's been a while but I'm back back
in the house back on me chess I've been
I've been busy the last few days had no
time for streaming also the Wi-Fi hasn't
been the best let's play E chord this
game and for this stream I'm just gonna
play the rapid arena and I'm gonna play
this pan off attack line you take twice
on d5 and then develop and usually white
delays playing d4 just to accelerate
development I take c3 is a move probably
now is a time for d4 and then just
develop the bishops this guy's playing
really quickly I'm tempted to play
Bishop c4 and threaten Bishop take f7
but then he'll probably play e6 and my
bishop will be misplaced so a Bishop e2
is a normal move Bishop e5 is an
aggressive move each three is a move
d5 is a move I forgot about d5 maybe I
can play a ch3 Bishop h5 d5 and then
wherever the knight moves I have Bishop
b5 check let's do that maybe he'll take
on f3 mmm so d5 this should take f3
queen take f3 it's a cheer I haven't
been looking at the chat so I will after
I destroy this guy d5 there's a funny
line d5 95 night 85 let's do that I
think black is in trouble
there's another funny line I don't know
if it works but might be 895 immediately
that might be too too crazy
hmm
I have a feeling might be a deserve s
move for him and I don't have to think
that move is possible actually that's a
playable move to probably Queen take f3
unless I want Queen a4 at some point
back winte got three Bishop b5 will come
he's gonna play this and then Bishop e5
97 should be better for a white but I
don't think it's like completely winning
yet Bishop b5 97 and Castle looks simple
enough a six a six Bishop a4 b5 Bishop
c2 I'll play a four at some point okay
yeah the problem for black is he's
severely underdeveloped and with a pawn
on d5 it's hard to it's hard for him to
develop and castle quickly enough and
I'm envisioning some scenario where I'm
gonna have this attack on the e pawn and
then his King will top be tied down to
the econ thanks for the sub-aqua
something game just disappeared aqua
laguna of something so earlier I said
Bishop c2 but now I'm thinking I Bishop
III and night c5 mmm push the pawn he
takes
d7 whoa wait was this that could
actually work Bishop b3 9c v d6
threatening mates he takes the thing and
then I play d7 if he takes with Queen I
win the rook if he takes with King I
have worked you one check let's do that
no guarantee hopefully Knight c5 but
it'll be nice if he does yeah now I'm
realizing that d6 can be met with a 6
and I have Queen c6 okay this is
interesting the problem for a block here
is there's several different targets and
the tactics are just favoring white
because my pieces are well placed he's
just not fully developed did he just
sign off wait is this green or gray
that's great he might okay he's back so
he probably forgot about d7 and white is
winning some material I'll win the queen
or the rook life is good now I can look
at the chess hello to people in the
chats double haze the first commenter to
eat Urbanski that was a nice game 17
moves yeah usually as far as I know in
these lines black should usually go for
an earlier g6 Bishop g7 and castling or
maybe even not and I take C 3 because
it's trading off the only developed
piece but then yeah he got into trouble
because this this diagonal is vulnerable
he was really just asking for d5 and the
tactic at that and there it was nice in
between moves okay
dr. tournament
hello to more people Torquay TV j CH SK
cask J lots of J's I'm doing well well
there's a lot of so many comments did I
see pashka one elite super blitz I did
not see that I really haven't been
online today
I slept in I've had such a long week I
needed some extra sleep ah the Yeti is
not back
I forgot I could have gotten the Yeti
for today I'm using my my portable go
mic which kind of gets the job done it's
probably a good sign that you asked if
the idea is back if the quality is good
enough to maybe be confused with the
Yeti you never liked t what's wrong with
you know okay engine God oh that's a
scary name that's a very scary name I
don't think I want to wish him luck at
least his rating isn't so scary
he's from Antarctica I didn't even
realize Antarctica had a flag let's play
let's just be solid
kamikaze pilot hello it's also a scary
name
well he's thinking I moved I moved to
there's much to think about
maybe he's just loading up my stream let
me know this
st. Louis was good it was a fun event it
was like four days of just entertainment
it was really busy for me oh let's be
solid let's playing them though or a
Queen's Indian or a qgd play qgd that's
my main my main repertory what I just
want to be solid yeah Bishop g5 ah so I
could I could maybe go into a Cambridge
Springs let's try it
I've been so frustrated lately at least
on me chess that no one ever goes into
the Cambridge Springs but it's about to
happen just play III okay we have a
Cambridge Springs I can't remember if
I've I can't remember the last time I
played this on stream probably played it
at some point it's an opening that I
recommend for for lower level players
like anyone below mm I think I think
this can be a very effective opening to
put the pressure on whites from very
early on because there's multiple
pressure points and there's multiple
ways for Locke to increase the pressure
so I like to teach this opening to
students it's easy to teach fun to play
do I ever play Queen b6 when someone
plays an early Bishop g5 probably not
now I have to remember this is slightly
embarrassing because there's two
different options here at Bishop d3 is
not supposed to be a good move but I
have to remember why I'm gonna take on
c4 first and Bishop takes c4 and this is
actually a fork
I'm forking two things blacks just
winning material this is a great thing
about the Cambridge Springs as Bishop d3
is just a mistake on move seven I
learned this I my first coaches taught
this to me I was such an enticing
opening because Bishop d3 is like the
most natural move for whites but okay
two things are attacked back is winning
material so so far today some some
decent opening preparation the last game
wasn't really preparation it was just
winning early in the opening but this is
still preparation he's debating which
things you allow me to to capture yeah
Bishop f4 okay so I'll take a tall win
at least up on and then I'll go for
Bishop b4 so now I either want to trade
Queens or win a piece
[Music]
yeah rook c1 so the thing about this
position is White has a bit of
compensation I'm debating here do I have
to take on d2 probably yes Queen B -
rooks you - okay I'll take so it's still
gonna take work from this position like
I'm up upon but this Bishop is terrible
he has two bishops decently placed
thinking keen e7 here there's no need to
castle and I control d6 preventing any
sort of Bishop d6 someday I probably
want to play e5 like f6 rook GAE 5 or
maybe c5 like b6 Bishop e7 c5 it's gonna
take a little bit of slow play to try
and unwind my pieces so now I'm thinking
b6
a four is kind of discouraging 96 now I
could play Knight b6 right away Bishop
b3 95 kick the bishop and then create an
outpost with Knight B 4 and a 5 that
might be reasonable and I gained tempo
along the way yeah let's do that
now the one thing if he allows me to
take on c4 nevermind I was gonna say it
could have been some opposite color
Bishop any game I mean I guess he could
still take shots of quarry bishops but
then this makes my bishop happy and off
the color bishops don't mean like dead
draw I mean they grind him down here
have the extra pawn I just have to make
sure not to trade off all the rooks you
might want to play a six so maybe I mean
if Bishop d7 and rook e1 is really
annoying so I might have to play a six
myself which I don't really want to do
I could play no I can't play Bishop by 5
because a6 what to do
King d7 looks really bad but maybe a
decent move with idea that I'm not
making any any concessions and I want to
play b6 in Bishop e7 King d7 feels like
a concession
but I think it's yeah it keeps the
options open if I play a six it's just
so committal and then all my pawns are
fixed does the thing is when when a six
is played his two pawns fix my four pots
which is not a pleasant situation so I
want to play b6 and trying get rid of
this pesky a pawn or even play b5 and
just have a passed pawn so Rick B one's
a good move I still have to untangle I'm
thinking h5 or f6 g5
yeah his bishops really annoying because
I can't play rook b8 let's start with h5
try and get some sort of play on the
Kings side X anion finally caught a
stream yeah welcome to those of you
whose your first time here like watching
live I think a lot of people start just
watching on YouTube and then slowly they
might met they migrated over to twitch
okay at least I have a time advantage h4
is a good move and he's playing he's
playing decent moves put the rook on eh
try and find a slightly more useful
square I don't really know what the plan
here is for black maybe the plan is to
play rook e7 King here and then develop
the bishop to make sure this pawn is
protected that's a scary move I don't
think he has a threat though because of
a six I can still play b6 so I'll
continue with my plan
not sure how effective this plan is
going to be so the problem is if I try
King ee8 next move he has a six and then
I see pawn is less defended have mercy I
can't have mercy on this guy it's not an
easy position to win but at least
everything is under control
like I'm up upon I'm up on time there's
no risk of losing it's a great situation
to be in and just because I can't win
immediately doesn't mean I should panic
so maybe f6 always play off six except
us you want to know if he plays a 6 b 6
rook C - I have rookie 6 so f6 sort of
tries to restrict the bishop maybe some
day play g5 in some sense it's just a
waiting move
I'm envisioning some day if he plays
rook be one here and then someday Bishop
f5 with tempo that would be nice that I
can bring five rook to d7 to defend b7
this is a positional struggle
also envisioning some ideas of bring the
King to f5 to prepare g5 because that's
one thing about these n games and King
activity can be pretty important
well I got rookie 3 rookie 3 the e pawn
has three defenders so you probably met
rookie six I just don't see what the
rook does on e6 I play rookie seven cuz
b7 is my biggest issue here and in order
to mobilize my bishop I have to over
defend the pawn so it's it's good he's
thinking like he probably just doesn't
know what to do I mean I don't know
exactly what to do either but as long as
it's his time ticking I can't really
complain Hollow to go of Adame welcome
there's no increment - so okay he plays
rook b1 so I assume that's just a
waiting move he's waiting for this so he
can play this calculating b5 on passant
- okay - and then it doesn't lead to
anything so maybe now rook c6 makes
sense - over the fence e6 but then
there's no great follow up
maybe in g6g six rook g7 + g5 have to
come up with something this might be a
nothing plan like this make no sense but
at least hopefully it will make him
think so that's all I need
did he just move back and forth okay
he's just wasting time so let's make him
think well this might have some merit
like g5 can open some file create some
weakness especially if that file opens I
can keep gaining space on the kingside
aha well that's good so I made him so
scared about GFI that he's taking
measures to control or try and prevent a
prevent g5 by targeting this H pawn but
now he's loosened the attack on c6 which
means now I have time do I have time for
King e6
maybe King d8
kingi it could make more sense because I
want my bishop to develop more actively
it's still difficult to untangle but it
feels like I'm making progress and for
this dream I'm not taking challenges the
Bishop f5 comes with tempo whoa
I don't want iTunes go away yeah this
dream I'm just playing the rapid arena
so now I have rook c8 he doesn't have
rook b1 but what does rook c8 do doesn't
really do much
maybe my my king wants to go here so
that I have this in this
maybe I should have started with King
yet rather than king D it's why not keep
my king on white like a light square
yeah maybe that's probably right I
should have kept the King on light but
not it wasn't relevant what color is
square the relevance was I I free up the
d8 square for the rook and he's just
wasting time again so I can do this I
think it's tricky now but okay it feels
like he doesn't have a plan he's giving
me a lot of free time yeah he's just
moving back and forth so I'm gonna get
my so-called ideal setup now I want to
bring the King back to see it maybe I
start with rookie 7 so I want access to
this square okay
so this is the way I improve
so it feels more comfortable now it
still takes work to break through I'm
wondering maybe if this rook should be
on h8 - then prepare g5 I could also
play Bishop b4 provoke f3 mmm let's
start with this g5 take take Bishop e5
so I'll have to throw in PL play rook h7
of funny configuration ah so he finally
plays this a6 move so now c6 could be a
potential problem but I'll have Bishop
d7 also have King g7 just debating
whether to play b6 or b5 probably be 6
yeah this is um this is very safe you
can't attack c6 another time and now a6
is weak potentially I think I'll put the
bishop back on d7 and then improve the
King maybe bring the King to f5 now he's
asking for a g5 I think I'll start with
this so maybe with some idea of g v g5
take take take take take f2 hmm don't
know if it leads to much well let's
bring the king in he's gonna flag I
wasn't playing to flag him it's just
such a long kind of drawn-out position
and now I'm winning upon her know he has
Bishop d6 but they're all in h4 now when
f2
up to pawns more pawns or a week ooh
free Bishop it's interesting idea
okay good game engine gud scary name uh
uh was a weird game he fell into an
opening trap but then it wasn't easy to
win that position and sometimes this is
what happens even when your opponent
fall opponents fall into opening traps
it still takes a lot at work to win a
game and a position like this is not
easy to win and I'm beginning to
remember that Bishop b4 might not might
not actually be the best move here
because in some sense it's committing to
giving away the bishop here in this line
I don't really want to trade off my dark
sweet bishop maybe I should have played
Knight f6 check analysis board oh wow so
engine is not impressed with black it's
just equal this is there any way to get
an advantage there mmm 94 immediately no
I mean of course I'd rather be black
just up a pawn I feel like the engine
doesn't understand this sort of position
anyway because black should be able to
untangle
but yeah it was the fights okay back to
tournament 220 third place there's 50
minutes left
I joined very late I joined after 1 p.m.
okay let's lady for today is an e4 type
of day at least without lights I tend to
like to play e4 more against lowering
the players just an easier opening to
play for a win with we verbanski tried
to play me today I remember when you
said that in a turn like it was a
tournament over a thousand players and
you ended up playing me it was
incredible
he just gave up oh he didn't move okay
whoa I moved up like a hundred places
with one win on a streak a Brooklyn boy
in first place I'm not accepting
challenges now in fact maybe I'll just
change my preferences preferences
another d4 okay chess woman thirty two
from Russia interesting plays all the
other rapid chess okay I'll be solid
maybe you'll have another Cambridge
Springs lady five it might happen to
Cambridge Springs in a row please play
Knight f3 yes okay this will be fun oh
she knows what she's doing Bishop take
f6 is a good move 92 I don't think is
necessary though I had to actually have
a student who plays the Cambridge
Springs and I was going over this other
day because usually white should play
either a bishop taking f6 or 92 but the
combination of those moves it just
allows Bishop d6 now I want to go for a
5k might be 3
doesn't make me too upset just move move
back I want to play you five maybe I
want a castle first
let's see five makes me very happy
Maui five should be strong strong when
it comes D five right away
I feel like white shadow plate f4 make
it a bit more difficult for me having
trouble talking was having some cookie I
was eating a cookie earlier and there's
like cookie crumbs stuck in my throat
not a pleasant situation but this is a
pleasant situation Pawnee five will
trade on e5 and then there might be some
great gift possibility if white castles
here at Bishop to H to look like the
pieces are almost all in the Queen side
okay Knight d4 the Queen e7 is a double
attack I'm threatening this and this
Queeny seven mean why not make white
think it's funny but night night back to
be three might be the only move I don't
see any other moves and I can look to
play d4 maybe well that's a free piece
that was generous yeah some nice
openings today Koppel Cambridge Springs
wins in the first game that caro-kann
win so the previous game my opponent
didn't show up
yeah White's position crumbled there
like a cookie 64th place one point away
from 2300 now my rapid rating is not
been the best but ok big game play E for
again yeah I'm essentially sticking with
the same the same repertoire
if toilet noggin were here I would play
some exchange Roy
Queenie seven actually Queenie seven has
a funny trap to it there's a trap that
um that white can fall into if I play
Bishop c4 Knight f6 Knight g5 black can
play h6 if I take on f7 I lose a piece
but I don't think my opponent is playing
this knowingly I think I'll start with
Knight c3 Knight before bishops and
maybe ninety five is possible but let's
just develop all Castle and go over a d4
and this Queen will be terribly placed
maybe it's difficult to punish though d4
right away
oh there's a funny trap but it's not a
chat I was thinking b5 we trade in
Bishop d5 but the Queen would support
Bishop b7
okay let's play for preventing b5 g
sound my saturday is going pretty well
decent game so far I want to play d4
like I'm developed and castled my
opponent has only developed the Queen
and now is opening up the center this
cannot be good for black but why is it
not good for black d4 takes on e4 that's
annoying
maybe I just take and then go for a d4
later then d5 Volcom so I do have to
think if I play d3 and then I 4 can be
played an F for d4 I wanted to play 9h
for it but then Queen to h4 so I'm
wondering if d4 I can sack a piece like
might take you five pawn to e5 Queen h5
check
Queeny choose a move to
Queeny to could be nice
I might have to accept that I'm not
gonna punish this guy immediately which
is really aggravating
so Bishop take GA doesn't move this
could be interesting because in a lot of
lines might be my bishop gets hit so
like Bishop take GA up to 84
pawn to e4 Knight to e4 d5 the problem
is he for was is coming there
there's also rookie one rookie one
ticktick d5 my night moves to g3 and
this pawn is attacked
I think I'll do that just based on
intuition if I had more time I would
calculate more but the fact that I have
so many pieces developed something
should work out D for now he's playing
so fast well now this pawn is undefended
and there's a funny line if I take d5 I
can take here and then go for a d4 let's
do that used a lot of time he's just
used over 30 seconds I've used about 4
minutes
but this is a problem that his bishop is
blocked like both bishops are blocked
the king is just stuck and e4 will come
or some crazy sacrifice will come T for
now oh he wants to play e4 whoa
I'm not even clicking the mouse how did
this happen it's just wow it's just like
stuck to the mouse like usually it's
clicking dragged by clicked and unclick
now it's just stuck let's not Mouse slip
I've never seen that happen before
I don't even know what I did Oh can i
plate 9 h4 with my g6 ideas I think
there's two main ideas here either d4
and 9 h4
d 4e 4 is critical and then that H 4 and
then D 5 mmm let's just play 9 H 4
because I defend the pawn Knight G 6 is
unstoppable and D 5 just runs into
knight g6 an e5 would fall so I know d4
feels more natural but this just feels
better okay I'm out of tea it's always a
disappointment when I'm out of tea I
checked my cup and then I checked my cup
like 10 minutes later and I'm still out
of tea but knight g6 is pleasant I could
take take with either thing oh this is
just crushing it's just a matter of how
to crush him and not flag
let's do this looks fun he files now
open if he plays Kim d7 I have this if
he plays King d8 I have my take h8 with
the threat of 9 f7 okay
when the Queen
so now what's material he has rook in
peace for a queen but I'm still still
more developed than him maybe 96 or
Queenie - I'll start with Queenie -
threatening some discovery is in
threatening Queen takes e4
don't really want to lose this pawn so I
guess I can play g4 I'm just being
greedy this pawn is really strong this
pawn is bound to fall and once I take
here I'll have Queen f7 ideas unless he
Queen side castles but that's okay
d for perhaps
or d3 I'm so indecisive let's play d3
keep this rank open maybe now 96
yeah like g6
and then Bishop f4 will probably come
very soon I just want to trade rook h7
wanna move maybe just might take out
steak first
and queen d4 I want to play Bishop f4
next and rook e1 and with Queen g4 I'm
preventing queenside castling or not
okay so now if I take guess he wins g4
tick tick
I have 97 check no way no I don't
let's just play Bishop f4 keep things
simple
should watch my time
I'm just going to improve this why not
this is the only open file on the board
I'm up some ponds I haven't lost a
single pot yet so I have three ponds and
the Queen for rook and Bishop so I can
just trade everything let's play rook e7
just go in for the kill
I think this rook is completely stuck
Queen e5 Volcom or maybe Queen C 3 or
maybe neither fades
two minutes is more than enough time to
to win this let's play Queen afore I
would really like to make 9f8 work dinah
favorite H 896 looks to be working this
is a pin this is a 10 this is a double
attack in 96 when is a rook
okay I was a strange opening just to
show people what I was referring to at
the very beginning
Queeny 7 has a trap to it where ok the
most normal move for white is Bishop to
c4 Knight f6 it's disable engine
analysis for a moment and then if white
plays Knight g5 here well I can play h6
and then if Bishop take f7 or 90s 7 I
believe black is better even though the
scores might not indicate that I get
Bishop take f7 White's now losing a
piece one of these are falling and if
Knight take f7 there's rook age 7 and
with d5 coming black is also winning a
piece because it's Knight is trapped so
just a weird variation anyway back to
tournaments maybe time for one or two
more games
had so much chest this week sometimes
it's hard to play more chess I'm top 50
Wow 873 people I've only played I've
only played four games one of those
games my opponent didn't show up time
for me to play a trap you mind most of
the lines I played so far have been
slightly choppy I think like every game
today I've had a pretty nice position
from the opening so I'll try and keep up
that trend I think of 1551 huckleberry
90 good luck d4 again ok I'll be more
ambitious with scheme III well now I
have to be ambitious let's play c5 maybe
to go for some kind of Pannonian Kings
Indian set up he's trying to be solid
and played b6 and there should be seven
the setup I think whoa was unexpected
I'm gonna say the setup I was planning
to go for it was double fee and keto
with eventually five but now this just
looks Pleasant like that was a good
trade deep on for deep on I like to tell
my more big beginner students this but
in the opening center pawns are usually
worth like one point two points in terms
of just point value and wing pawns like
a and B pawns and G and H pawns are
worth like point eight points so a
situation like this it's a nice trade
for black
so now it's a matter of just completing
development I would like to play d5 it
allows Bishop b5 check so how to develop
most efficiently g6 actually no I'll go
for d5 Bishop b5 evolve just continue
developing and maybe I'll play a 6 or
not I could play e5 or a 6
let's buy e5 that's some more the most
principled move it doesn't happen too
often when I'm black and just have a
massive Center like this so ok the plan
is to complete development and then
someday try and open things up
gofer this like thing about this
position is white setup isn't easy to
crack but it's very passive so the
strategy is just to kind of keep
improving to try and do some squeeze
let's play Queen b6 ideas of c4 because
this is a target this is a target this
is a target III is actually difficult to
defend if I play c4 I don't think I can
defend III unless he wants to play King
f2 maybe d4
d for looks pleasant and you stopped me
from playing c4 but if I play d4 he
plays efore mmm it's still a nice
position for black
debating whether to leave the tension
well I think I'll clay d4 I'm just
trying to play principled moves yeah
okay the centre closes go for this
manoeuvre I'm happy with the position
but it could be a long game these
positions are not easy to win right away
unless I have does this work d3 bishop
take D 3 and then Queen here I'm
threatening the bishop and I'm
threatening this double attack
d3 could be a beautiful tactic
he has nine f2 so d3 Bishop take d3
queen d69 f2 that's unfortunate
thanks for the cheer but I have to focus
let's play rook to you at first the
threat is very obvious but maybe he'll
miss it
yeah mindless cargo
thanks for the bits ok he just hung upon
he's allowing d3 well maybe it's a trade
of pawns let's just take
I want to win this game and have time
for another game so I'll try it off the
pace Knight c3 looks nice Knight c3
Queen e1 Queen g6
neither for
if you're like this should be easier but
slightly frustrating I'm gonna play
Knight g6
we'll just go after e5 hello MJ nikkor
with no vowels in that name thanks for
the comments it's good to see a lot of
new people here today people that come
from YouTube introduced to twitch Bishop
h4 looks very enticing Bishop h4 because
where does the Queen move maybe g3 and
then ripped a key five there's some
crazy line where he takes on g6 I take
his queen and then he starts winning a
lot of material but that should be good
for black Queen c6 is also enticing but
that runs into Bishop f3
so I'm calculating rook take e5 queen f2
and then maybe just Bishop f6 yeah this
is just a great position for luck it's
my bishop is monsterous my knight is
monstrous oh this could be some mating
idea I need to how can I make it work
though I could just take the bishop on
each five Cs one check making sure I'm
not getting back earning mated I have a
knight on g6 and I just want my e2 which
isn't mates 9 f4
just looking for the quickest way to
meet those 95 that doesn't trap the
queen a king's a rook
okay there's so many wins here I'll just
take on that four and then go for an ie
to Nathan
welcome back Nathan thanks for the
thousand bits long time no see just in
time for this brutal finish I just have
to make sure not to plunder a queen uh
fates and life will be good okay let's
take this now I'll be up a rook and I'll
be meeting very soon
I've used a lot of time this game took
energy okay he takes the bishop so night
III I'm just looking for a meets my h3
I'm just couldn't gonna play that g6 I
just want to win the Queen they can
resign
how should you practice chess there's
lots of ways to practice chess can play
play online play on me chess play longer
games if you want to improve orally
chess org slash puzzles I think that's
the right link and you can just train
tactics or you can just watch me
it's a a decent form of practice so
there's about 20 minutes left in the
tournament I think I'll have time for at
least one more game let's take this
this is gonna be made somehow some way
where's the mate Queen c3 Bishop here
more bits from Nathan back at school a
very busy
yeah I understand school is busy I've
been here before but but yeah thanks for
stopping by do you appreciate it I feel
like a good portion of my viewers are
still in school one way or the other
back to tournaments yeah that was a
strange opening let's go pack
top 30 hopefully I'll get to play at
least one stronger player have I tried
to contribute to leach us as a developer
no I have not I have reported a few bugs
but apart from that I don't have the the
coding skills to contribute code so I
just contribute content that's easier
approach what did I study in terms of
Chester in terms of school in school I
studied a pursuit a major called
interactive digital media which is all
about emerging technologies relating to
media so web development design
photography video production marketing
so anyway okay I'm playing another
decently low rated player let's play I'm
just gonna stick with the same
repertoire I haven't played a French yet
play what I usually play against lower
rated players the toon rights attack
d4 is a move d4 is very playable usually
gives white a a comfortable way to
develop
and I like this position even though
Locke has more space the Knights on the
Kings side make it easy to attack I also
keep my King safe where my castle Bishop
d6 he wants me to play e5
maybe I'll play you five the issue with
E 5 is it gives him the d5 square it
opens up this diagonal so it's a trade
off
oh let's do it gives me the e4 square
and I'll accelerate developments also
this night is going to have a harder
time developing if he moves back to e7
and maybe while I'll do I'll put my
Bishop on e4 and queen on e too and try
and restrict his development
we'll start with Queenie - kind of
hoping he castles here because that
would be nice
okay Knight g6 is playable
I could play Knight h5 and question his
g7 pod
because nine that four is coming well
it's mine h5 past pawn yeah a long time
no see all the people I haven't seen in
a while returning today do I make more
mistakes putting less effort against low
rated players I just try and play good
moves
but sometimes yeah it's it's possible to
be careless I try and find ways to make
the game interesting so I don't get
bored castling but sometimes I get tired
which is maybe easily confused with
boredom but chess is tiring sometimes
the problem here is he has two more ways
to attack the epon I have too many more
ways to defend the epon past 199 thanks
for the sub so this system of
development maybe wasn't the best
approach
thinking I should castle
wait
no I have I have serious problems to
solve but maybe the a castle in Ricky
one let's do it
I'm not happy with this position I
mishandled it somehow maybe Bishop d3
this is just the wrong idea had to take
a bit more precautions welcome back sole
artistic and lemon chief so yeah this is
a problem I can't play rookie one cuz he
winds up on I would like to like go
crazy an attack him but that's hard to
do so I think I'll just take on g6 and
then retreats and I'll hold on to the
park
interesting so he opens a file but in
some ways taking with f-pawn is
weakening to the epon no it's double
edged black has two bishops that this
bishop is garbage until it develops and
meanwhile I want to complete development
- it's gonna be a fight I'm going to
really like this pawn to come to f4 but
that's hard to achieve because my knight
is always going to be tied down
g5 while so he wants to remove my night
so he can win the pond
so maybe h3
now I would like to play 94 and just
double attack or maybe just d3 first
but I think it was necessary to stop gee
for now oh he's allowing the trade night
take g5 probably Knight takes e5 golf
throwing rook e1 I might actually like
to play c4 very soon like if he plays h6
probably the most expected move I could
throw in the c4 if he takes I take back
with the D pawn unleash the bishop open
the d file
if he doesn't play h6 maybe he doesn't
have to g6 I was unexpected g6 is very
strange I have no idea how it helps them
and it just it's weakening to f6 which I
can't exploit right away
let's play c4
I just want to remove the Queen open the
position up which might feel strange
because block has a bishop pair but his
bishops are very much restricted do I
have a threat here of trapping the Queen
I think I do
please play b6
actually I like the situation all he saw
its so I was thinking that he would be
so inclined to defend this pawn now I
can take I was hoping for like b6 or if
d1 would trap the queen but okay now I
just went the pond for free and rook d1
will come okay now it's a good position
because f6 is really weak h6 is weak he
didn't have rook take out three earlier
which may have been a good move
okay his queen is gonna get kicked
around it's great when I can kick around
the Queen and improve the pieces at the
same time hello I'm singer I'll come
back I sound sick sick as in awesome or
sick as in not feeling well yeah I'm a
little bit burnt out huh from the recent
past few days I've been I've been
struggling with allergies too it's been
difficult
elastic hold I might play I'm not sure
if I play I have to register soon hello
if she I did not completely kill Carlsen
I just beat him in one game let's play a
night at 6:00 yeah this is looking very
pleasant most of his pieces are doing
nothing on the Queen side and my pieces
are doing something on the Kings side
it's a play Bishop h6 I want to bring
the other night in NASA courts I'll look
into that
so his Brooke is about to be trapped
it's funny rookie seven bishop f8
yeah this is too much fun
wondering if I have anything stronger
rookie seven
maybe 46
and they should that fates good enough
rookies completely trapped yeah I felt a
little bit uncomfortable at some point
when I had to take on g6 but now I'm
feeling very comfortable at least over
the board ninja welcome back
lots of people returning okay let's take
in ripped e7 o queen c6 could be a
problem actually maybe it's not a
problem just scared me for a moment
there it's probably not a problem yeah
it's not a problem let's do this
Queen c6 all play Queen g4
Oh h7 is hanging - I completely forgot
about that but I would rather take on
each segment with a rook rather than a
night okay so I'm not getting mated in
one good book to improve visualization
is a book called forcing moves which i
think is a good book I had a friend who
read forcing moves in high school and he
went from like 1,200 to 1,800 within
like a year or two but I think it trains
other things in visualization or in
addition to visualization but it's a
great book a fall thing ape is currently
reading forcing moves interesting how do
I win immediately I really want to play
Queen h4 but that would get me then so
what to do 9 f7 well there's so many
ways to win this I'm just so indecisive
let's play rook t1 threatening this
Riemann hypothesis is back I could have
played that three but been Feingold told
me never to play off three okay let's
take with check yeah this is complete
destruction King g7 I take you six this
will be a funny mates King f7 f8 mates
are king h6 wreck h8 mates
so there's four minutes left in the
tournament I don't know when pairings
close but this could be the last game
yeah it's very possible this will be the
last game and I broke 2300 I didn't even
realize it
I was twenty two ninety-nine at some
point one just enough games so this guy
this guy is probably crying you played a
good game up until a certain point what
was a mistake oh yeah he should've
played aged six just defend g5 I was
impressed he defend anything against
rook d1 maybe he heard me on stream
saying I was threatening to drop the
Queen
have you ratings on Leech s compared to
chess comm I'm not entirely sure I'm
sure
analysis could be done maybe it varies
from Player to Player but hey I gained
one rating points okay
I think that was a decently successful
tournament I don't want to play another
game
I think I want to end it there thanks
bull thing for the the hundred bits I
think it's time to get outside and walk
around get some fresh air I want to do
already forgetting I wanted to do
something oh I wanted to say hi to
toilet noggin I'm just dropping by
you're dropping by right when I'm about
to end the screen but overall I think
the games were instructive hopefully
people enjoy that I'll probably put this
on YouTube at some points but yeah apart
from that thanks everyone for watching I
might be back later tonight
there's a very strong possibility
because I finished work this week this
week was so hectic if if people sent me
messages I'm planning to respond
probably later tonight's before or after
my next stream to answer the question if
I coach my schedule is getting busier
but you can find out more information
using the coach command and that will
take you to my coaching profile on me
chess so a goodbye everyone and let's
just raid let's rate Fiona Fiona chedda
chedda
who is currently streaming she's been
streaming for a long time
is she still alive ah she is okay
excellent
okay bye guys I'll see you in the future
which is probably going to be tonight's
adios